We have a very special guest in the bra your house today.
May I present to you Mister Jean Butler,
also known as all Man's a Wilder.
Here in your kitchen, this is where it all happens.
I've come to Oklahoma to sign Prairie Man Books,
but you presented an irresistible opportunity.
One of my favorite things in the world,
which is chocolate chip cookies.
So we're about to make a batch.
Chocolate chip cookies, ladies and gentlemen.
Can't get enough of it. Jen has a great recipe.
I'm game. Let's make chocolate chip cookies.
We start with the melted butter.
Add a little bit more. Okay,
now we're gonna add 3/4 of a cup of brown sugar,
one egg. I'm putting a dash of vanilla.
Perfect. Wow,
that's more than a dash.
I'm adding one and 1/3 cups of flour.
Adding a pinch of baking soda.
A pinch. Half a bag of semi sweet chocolate.
I'm, like,
trying to convince Dean to eat the.
The cookie dough. That doesn't take much convincing.
This is for you. Oh,
I can lick this. Yeah.
Now we're gonna let it chill,
and then we're gonna bake these cookies.
They will go in the oven now for 10 minutes at 350 degrees.
Oh, my.
That's a good chocolate chip cookie.